and tonight here at six new information
about an argument that turned deadly in
an upscale north valley neighborhood the
man originally arrested for murder is
out of jail the shooting happened around
four in the morning on rome boulevard
which is between bradley and decatur
close to the costco shopping center that
is where 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough joins us now live and madison
the man was charged with murder but now
he's not
32-year-old daniel gehen was originally
charged with murder here at his home
that you can actually see in the far
distance behind me well tonight he's now
charged with carrying a concealed weapon
and possession of a stolen vehicle the
district attorney will now review the
open murder charge it's unclear at this
time what new evidence changed this but
it definitely changed this neighborhood
i went outside and the street was just
full of police
and they were trying to get him to come
out it's a morning neighbors won't soon
forget blue and red lights and police
tape thursday word spread fast of a
murder at this home danielle smith says
there's been a lot of police calls to
this residence before metro has been
there you know
more than a handful of times so we
weren't at all surprised according to
police a fight broke out between two men
and one was shot it's unclear what the
argument was about and if this was a
case of self-defense
neighbors tell me there are two houses
on the lot and they see a lot of cars go
through they also say they're not sure
if the owner lives there or rents it out
there's eight to ten people going in
another all the time we did not know
that and in this lot here which
they own also
he's moving dirt around and
has hoses ever i don't know what he's
doing it is of a
great concern because we've been having
issues in here with the car break-ins
so yeah so
it's a
it's a concern officers that were coming
around kind of reassure everybody of the
local neighborhood here
they they had indicated that neither of
the two men involved were actually
residents of that home you know it's
obviously unsettling because this has
been an extremely
peaceful quiet neighborhood for so long
as for the man who died the coroner has
yet to release his name meanwhile daniel
gehen was let out of jail on his own
recognizance and told by a judge to stay
out of trouble a hearing on these
charges is expected for next month of
course we will be here to keep you
updated reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now